[Music]
Salam alaikum warahmatullah better care
to brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys well in sha Allah welcome
to this specific show where we're going
to be shut up talking to a Bravo a young
brother who got in contact with me
I've spoken to his family spoke to his
mom spoken to his aunties well and we're
going to inshallah hear his story the
stuff that he was involved with how he
wants to get out of it why what's
happened all of that kind of stuff is
workmansh allah and why he had to run to
birmingham and now inshallah he is
planning to obviously we can't disclose
his next actions why he wants to do for
his safety but Salaam alaikum
okay biography okay so I'm gonna I'm
gonna call you I'll just give you a name
I just quite a bit for now yeah okay all
right so tell us your story obviously
it's regarding gangs and stuff like that
yeah but tell me how you got into it
yeah and from there on we'll just tell
me the events that occurred so like why
like why did you find the need so so so
take me to a like a young sirs mind yeah
cuz obviously we want to understand
where you guys are coming from and we I
do have some kind of like I can relate
you in certain ways in my diary I never
saw drugs I knew people that did yeah
like you know so heroin and crack myself
so I don't know the in-depth but what
makes youngsters
my pickup wall to be honest I wanted to
be an actor okay okay coming into you
we're not going to yeah it's easy money
for you again hmm
okay so you know when you said you was
carrying we're talking about weapons or
drugs or both
okay so okay what do you think is it
just like okay for example that you gave
up I'm not finding a job is it the money
is it is that in any other influences
like would you say that influence is a
young person's mind to go down the road
besides besides making money okay why
did you want to make money
the point is this amount of money what's
the reason behind like I just wanted to
do it myself so when I hit at the age of
16
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah mm-hmm okay so would you
say right
obviously you're young and you're seeing
that for example things that are seen as
like cold or how you should be so
leaving that society certain music
certain videos do the 11 they have an
impact on youngsters
because we're not far I was just two
music videos that were based on my area
find another area just listen you're
just sending shots my music you can get
this worth of money this work for thing
money get you anything
hmm okay so so so you saying that you
know music drew is it true music I think
that plays are oh yeah yeah and the
thing is people people just say okay
ever it's music it's it's an art you
know can we say that this is an art
that's killing people exactly you know
and it's having this impact on you
because I didn't they you're being
exposed to this you know this kind of
music and it's hype it's a gas you know
especially music music has a massive
effect on your brain I suppose into
music yeah and it's it's not a drug you
know I cannot remember when you know
we're gonna call fire or something like
that but just listen to me just get hype
and I didn't do drugs my friend would do
drugs and I didn't do drugs
I bought hyped and guests off the music
I don't think and imagine if I if I had
drugs if I took drugs on top of that I
don't like it's like a person who's
flipped you it he's ready to kill do
anything you get it so I think music
plays a role what about that for example
you see in these music videos all these
girls and stuff like that you know as a
young man do you think that plays a
pressure because I didn't they most of
the times you know as men you know our
weaknesses woman yeah and this
youngsters feel like okay you know what
for me in order for me to you Annie get
that kind of girls or for example would
you say that the way certain girls are
back they won't look like a bad boy yeah
that would be the columns I understand
the factors that's causing people this
trigger elements do you think that plays
a role
yeah yeah okay okay a warrant every time
they just helping me okay so okay use
involved in gangs yeah so did you use
your selling yeah so things went wrong
what happened so how to talk
but tell me what kind of happened in
doing so okay so alright so you took
this guy's stash yeah you took his line
yeah so this is the line so people from
mistake and correct me that they'll have
a line they'll build this line so this
line is worth money now because this is
worth a lot of money so depending on the
line so if you take the line of that
person because you need to understand
these people who are addicts
they know that's good you know why yeah
okay okay all right okay so then you and
yeah so basically and then afterwards
this happened so they plop he was it was
it the one with the Moscow without the
musk so without the mosque yeah okay so
and the be brother go to be his
girlfriend
okay so how do you know how he died like
what
they stopped it how old is he how old
was it I would yeah so he was stabbed to
death and he was telling me that he
accepted Islam he was given him though
he just wanted to come it's quite it's
quite strange isn't it like for example
like you know you guys are Muslim and
this guy even like it's not you doing
dower
like you're different how about you're
also doing the Haram so it just shows a
place like this for the youngsters they
like the it's like they have their Dean
strong kind of they have that is that
you know love for it and at the same
time so it just shows like either
they're absolute hypocrites or they just
screw up in the system
you know back what would you say I would
you say these people are just two-faced
like you know like or would you say like
somebody or ask and say okay how how you
get someone to accept Islam and at the
same time you selling drugs
what would you say that person would you
say that person yes I'm two-faced or no
I'm just co-op in the system I don't add
like would you say but cuz of desires so
then it doesn't make you really two
faces some it's just basically you know
you're falling short because of you know
so yeah you know so
ya know we need to make sure you do so
yeah cuz we went to Burma coming up
remember my sermon Instagram yeah
yeah you missed your Instagram and then
I spoke to you I spoke to your auntie as
well yeah it's it's it's serious you
know if there's any parents watching
this cause you know sometimes we don't
understand the severity you know
sometimes just like yeah okay yeah we
feel like out that our kids are
exaggerating you know and this is
important because this is your life on
the line you know cause if these people
catch you you know even me I get
concerned for you cause you know that's
what's it you know if you've got a whole
message me because you know it's it's I
didn't eat it's it's sad man you know
like have you repented okay so like I
said before man you know if there's
people watching this you know I gave a
reminder yesterday's role that you need
to understand you know these friends etc
yes no matter how much they love you man
look even your own mum your mum is the
one that's points you know if there's
one person that's kind of Christ it's
going to be a mum and your mom's gonna
cry for what yeah two years you're gonna
be forgotten you know it's it's it's
human nature and let alone your friends
yeah I've been to you know I was going
example of one prophet that I know you
died didn't get you up I died and his
friends at the funeral how they were
like it's there's nothing they ruined
his life in this life and then even when
they buried him they were talking about
yours and linking up and party involved
that's how quick like you you just bury
the guy but that's how quickly just
forget you and the postcard was that
you're fighting over this it's just so
straight
that you don't even you fighting over
something that you don't own it's
something that's man-made this isn't
it's just a an idea you know this is our
area like nothing belongs to you there
yeah you've just made up this imaginary
world in your head and you're living
it's like GTA you're literally in GTA
and you're thinking you're something and
you don't own nothing and you're killing
people over you feeling people over a
postcode
yeah that's road sign that says it
whatever postcode area is you don't you
don't even own that and you're killing
people and the prophet sallallaahu
seldom said that a day will come where
the person that's killing doesn't know
why he's killing and the one who's being
killed doesn't know why he's being
killed for you don't know why you're
doing it you're just doing it because of
hype and gas anything it's all happy
days and it's not you know you see like
you know your friend has died you know
if you go prison what happened yeah
you're gonna be in a box room for all of
your life while your friends that they
probably not even gonna come see you
they're gonna forget about you you know
and it's good that you've woken up and
understood that reality you know and it
came at the cost of your friend dying
you know it came at the cost of someone
dying and that could have been you you
know you know that that could be new and
may Allah protect you you know because I
I'm gonna speak to your mum as well and
that you need to leave the country you
know because I didn't they
it's dangerous for you to be here you
know it's it's dangerous you can go
somewhere else but you know you might
get same influence and also you said
that you don't want to do that because
influence you bought this Haram money
actually you know his woman I had
friends man that it's big you know in
Jenny a crack heroin etc they would
never I've never seen them ever save
money I've never seen them ever ever
save money they just never there was no
burka like they'll be gambling
they lose their stash they have to go
and sell everything that they bought the
new TV the new this that the integral
sell all of that to realign that land
gets stolen you were enemies well I is
such a miserable life and it's such a
dirty life like yours are you talking
about yeah I'm talking about crack
heroin
yeah when they would put in these what
the whole yeah those wraps and then
they'll burn it and they carry in their
mouth yeah they'll carry in their mouth
when the police comes they after
swallowing they have to train their self
swallow it not literally down to the
stomach but you know that that can yeah
they keep it here yes so when the police
come sometimes when you see please
always come there they will try to grab
you by your mouth or your throat so you
don't swallow them yeah so they will do
that and to leave me you don't know
where gills - yeah that's what I'm gonna
say where they stash they have to stash
yeah
so it's disgusting and some of them
swallow it and some of them literally
your life is in danger this is it's so
disgusting yeah I enjoy Haley I would
see these friends it's so what like it's
such a vile vile life is unbelievable
yeah they would if they swallowed it
they have to go and defecate just
imagine this place it's it's absolutely
disgusting
you have to defecate look what kind of
online look up a lot of minutes you have
to defecate then you need to go and
search can you imagine to search those
pieces in your literally yours feces
like an animal an animal won't do that
yeah an animal when he defecates you
would put dirt on it like a cat a cat is
more human Yanni they were in this
aspect he needs to go and search that
it's disgusting and then if it pops in
your stomach you're good you're finished
yeah crap heroin in your stomach
straight you're finished this is
disgusting man I've seen it
it is absolutely vile and I don't know
what people are like understand the
money etc or llahi that lifestyle like
that going inside your own people for me
in carrying that your lives in they
enjoy you don't live in peace you're
Annie it's disgusting okay well I it's
absolutely vile and I think people that
are watching this should wake up you
know because I didn't day look he did II
couldn't like Janna you can wear the
latest clothes you know you can have the
cause if you're looking over your
shoulder but like I don't know what
piece you can have I could have the most
amazing car or whatever you want to call
it if I if I can't sleep properly if I'm
looking over my shoulder well like
that's the most depressing life ever
like I will rather earn
something halal small when I'm going to
sleep I have no concern I don't need to
worry about nothing when I'm driving my
car I don't need to think he's gonna
pull up he's gonna shoot me he's a key
one like it's that's why peace peace is
something that a lot of people rich
people yeah you go and earn their money
etc they all look for peace that's the
main factor in their life they say well
we don't have peace so you see it all
comes back to that you can have these
people don't do drugs and maybe they
might earn their money for demas haram
in different ways which is not illegal
in their aspect yeah acting or you know
rebar or alcohol whether they selling
they don't have peace and that's why I
says in the Quran only in the
remembrance of Allah do hearts find
peace so Allah saying that the only way
you're gonna find pieces in the my
remember in my remembrance so if there's
any youngsters watching this look every
Sunday I'm start this new thing where if
you guys instead of going to roam in the
streets doing harm stuff meet me come to
speaker's corner we can go eat together
we can pray together and shut up we're
going to be their reminders etc but for
brothers and sisters inshallah can come
on the day and we're trying to do more
youth work is well inshallah bum and
sisters and inshallah we ask you
insha'Allah to be careful keeping keep
us up-to-date in world what's happening
but I'm gonna speak to your mom to get
you out cuz you being here is dangerous
and your mum your mum new eating is to
understand that so yeah guys if you
ensure you benefit from this and if
there's anyone watching this please
change your life inshallah because I
didn't they
it's not worth it yeah you're poisoning
other people's children is all you need
to understand that because you is just
stuck to your drug you're destroying
families
yeah there's innocent people there but
you're getting them addicted to the
stuff you're destroying their life don't
think it's that one person that you're
giving it to you you're destroying it
laughs the mum their mum's going to
suffer you know so you destroy in
society and it's not worth it
what lies not work for all these people
most of my fake most of them are like
they're not even real gangsters they
just get you hyped etc they do your
dirty work and you're the one that's
going to suffer so yeah may Allah bless
you man I really appreciate it but is
there anything you want to say like
close the statement to the youngsters
kids yeah in Shaolin definitely and
we're gonna make sure if there's any
parents watching this please make sure
you talk to your children and inshallah
have that relationship do not disregard
what they say because if you do that
then if they can't talk to you then
don't be surprised if they go and talk
to they're bad friends and they're bad
friends tell them bad things you know
open up to them and listen tarnish Allah
may Allah bless you guys for listening
assalamu alaikum water how to lie better
good